ce sera jour de budget le 10 mars
prochain à québec les milieux d'affaires
en plusieurs attentes qu'ils ont
d'ailleurs présenté au ministre des
finances eric girard lors des
consultations prébudgétaires les grandes
priorités cap sur la croissance à long
terme accès à la main d'oeuvre
allègement du fardeau fiscal des
entreprises on va en parler avec michel
blanc lé président chef de la direction
de la chambre de commerce du montréal
métropolitain merci d'être là monsieur
leblanc on a entendu monsieur girard
aujourd'hui dire l'environnement ce sera
le thème dominant le coeur de ce budget
vous pensez quoi de ce cap qui est
introduit
écoutez je pense que c'est la bonne
chose à faire et on lui a dit le milieu
des affaires est très conscient que
collectivement nous des défis à relever
qu on investir dans le transport en
commun qu'on maintienne le cap sur
l'électrification des transports
peut-être le gouvernement plus d'un
objectif aussi plus ambitieux en à peu
près 15 % de la flotte gouvernementale
qui est électrifié le gouvernement
pourrait décider d'ici cinq ans il passe
à 50 % donc ça veut dire des budgets
renouveler les flottes plus rapidement
alors le gouvernement peut faire sa part
on parlait aussi plus loin il ya des
nouveaux concepts d'économie circulaire
ça existe aussi chez les entreprises
donc d'entreprises qui utilisent des
matières recyclées comme un train et
lorsqu'on dit au ministre c'est
peut-être que vous pourriez m'aider
incitatif pour que les entreprises
réfléchissent en ce sens
et si des projets d'économie circulaire
qu'elle dit qu'elle faisait plus la
possibilité de tester donc il ya pas de
blocage la part des entreprises c'est
plutôt une façon ou des moyens
d'embrasser ce virage oui oui écoutez
moi je perçois mieux des affaires très
mobilisés ils n'étaient pas tous dans la
rue avec greta mais ils ont bien compris
que c'est un avantage concurrentiel si
on bascule dans l'économie verte dans
l'économie propre vous sobre en carbone
le plus tôt possible
évidemment on dit au ministre il ne faut
pas faire que ça les surplus budgétaires
sont importants la robustesse de nos
finances publiques doit lui donner des
marges est d'abord il faut se garder une
manche l'économie ralentit et se faut
toujours avoir à l'esprit mais on dit
aussi réduisons la pression fiscale sur
les québécois souhaitent entreprise
s'appelle qu'on a entendu quand même pas
mal dans les derniers mois dix ans mais
le dernier budget la dernière mise à
jour
c'est surtout les particuliers qui en
profitent et les entreprises lèvent la
main 10 c'est notre tour c'est d'abord
les particuliers on n'est pas rendus en
fou réaliser que au québec on paie plus
d'impôts qu'à peu près partout ailleurs
en amérique du nord et donc on dit
continuer dans ce sens là peut-être
qu'il faut aussi les seuils à partir
desquels les niveaux les taux
d'imposition augmentent ça c'est une
chose pour les particules pour les
entreprises qu'on dit c'est attention
parce qu aux états unis il ya une
réforme très agressif et la réponse ici
elle n'a pas été concluant et le
président on le sait bien vu que ces
entreprises à un avantage ici america
first et nous on est sur le même
continent donc on dit au ministre des
finances
regardez la fiscalité nos entreprises il
faut baisser les taux d'imposition des
entreprises
il ya de la marge pour le faire ouais on
a entendu beaucoup françois legault
parler dans les dernières semaines même
de son objectif d'en faire plus
améliorer la compétitivité la
productivité et réduire l'écart avec
l'ontario est ce que vous pensez donc
que dont vous avez un peu la vente
ajoute vous n'êtes ni reçu avec vous
écoutez ce que je pense c'est que le
ministre ira partage cet objectif
la question qui nous pose souvent c'est
akalé raid vous voulez le faire et des
fois nous on voudrait qu'il aille plus
vite dans cette direction là c'est
normal
j'irai dans dans les priorités
budgétaires il faut pas oublier la main
d'oeuvre si on veut que notre économie
continue sur son erre d'aller la main
d'oeuvre c'est important et la
l'immigration l'intégration et
l'immigration les capacités que le mini
sur les barrettes avec son ministère
d'accueillir beaucoup d'immigrants de
faire fonctionner la plateforme harriman
on va avoir besoin que ça roule
rondement sa part que déjà des mesures
en place et des conseillers du ministère
d'emplois qui sont déjà sur le terrain
auprès des entreprises yari moi qui
existe c'est pas suffisant
écoutez on appris des retards jadis
systématiquement sur le traitement de
l'immigration le ministre
la difficulté l'été dernier puis c'est
pour ça qu'il avait suspendu le pecq le
programme le fameux programme de
l'automne dernier alors ce qu'on dit aux
ministres des girafes
assurez vous que le mini jeu les bretons
les ressources pour pouvoir traiter les
migrations très rapidement parce que les
entreprises ont besoin
il ya les migrants temporaires mais il
ya aussi toutes les migrations qu'on
veut bien arrimé aux besoins du marché
du travail ce sont des demandes je
voudrais que vous formulez mais que les
autres associations entreprises formule
aussi
parlez-vous pour montréal en particulier
de projets structurants vous en êtes
beau l'identifier quelques-uns
d'ailleurs pourquoi écouter à chaque
fois ce compte on est attentif à au
projet qui arrive et qui vont avoir un
impact sur l'économie on n'essaie pas
s'éparpiller
le premier qui est là depuis très
longtemps et il est temps qu'on tranche
et qu'on aille de l'avant c'est
l'agrandissement du palais des congrès
tous les centres de conférences à
travers l'amérique du nord ont pris de
l'ampleur et nous il devient de plus en
plus à l'étroit et donc on peut partir à
montréal les grandes foires commerciales
et tous ces spécialistes et tous ces
investisseurs potentiels ça c'est 1 2 on
voit tous le royal victoria cet immense
édifice sur la montagne qui vident
l'université mcgill en un projet il faut
l'occuper cet édifice il faut pas qu'ils
se détériore donc on dit au gouvernement
du québec aller de l'avant le projet de
méga lille est prêt il faut se commettre
à investir et le dernier c'est toujours
la décontamination des terrains de l'est
et ses vastes terrains c'est un
potentiel pour le développement
économique de montréal faire travailler
les gens de l'est de l'île dans des bons
emplois mais il faut commencer par des
contaminés ça va prendre des sommes
importantes et il ya des sommes allés
chercher à ottawa si québec mais
l'argent ottawa vont mettre l'argent et
on va partir la machine dans l'est de
l'île le mot clé la dame sur le blanc
cette somme importante parce que c'est
vrai qu'il ya de l'argent dans les
coffres à québec
et vous l'avez mentionné 2020 sera pas
l'année 2019 on n'aura probablement pas
une croissance aussi spectaculaire faut
être prudent on n'aura pas les moyens
tout faire s'il y avait une chose que
vous deviez choisir ce serait quoi
s'assurer que la main d'oeuvre
disponible parce que c'est le moteur de
l'économie si le problème le plus criant
si on veut créer de la richesse au
québec il faut que les entreprises
investissent et leur nervosité c'est la
main d'oeuvre on entendu monsieur gérard
faire une petite allusion encore aux
navires us aujourd'hui dire est ce que
ça pourrait freiner notre croissance est
ce qu il ya de l'inquiétude parmi vos
mains écouter les gens présentement qui
font des affaires en chine voit le
ralentissement mais c'est surtout les
gens qui s'approvisionnent en chine qui
se posent des questions dans quelques
mois si rien le s'améliorer alors on
n'est pas rendu là
moi je pense qu'il faut pas crier au
loup avant que lou soit là est
présentement c'est surtout les des
questions sanitaires plus que des
questions économiques du point de vue du
québec il nous reste dix secondes
est ce que monsieur girard s'est montré
ouvert à vendôme
oui ils aident les coutumes et les
erreurs on verra ce qu'a vraiment le
budget mais quand on échange et j'ai
bien senti qu'on se parle et on parle la
même langue merci beaucoup merci